so in the last few weeks there has been
some strange videos appearing online
strange articles talking about people
who are spitting or licking or you know
doing all kinds of disgusting things
into public food food that is in the
supermarket and then putting it back on
the shelf and so it is a pretty
disgusting subject but I thought it
would be important to talk about it
because it seems to represent a lot of
things about our society and a lot of
things which help us understand how
religious people are and what let's say
our modern liturgical actions look like
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so not very long ago there was a video
which showed up online of a guy who was
spitting into a into some tea iced tea
and then putting it back on the shelf
and this was just one more video among
several videos where we could see people
people licking ice cream putting it back
on the shelf there were there are
different videos of people doing that
and the question became why on earth
would anybody do that and of course the
first reason let's say the immediate
reason is because they want to be famous
they just want to attract attention they
want people to look at them but there
seems to be another reason behind that
or let's say a symbolic reason why this
particular action is taking place right
now
and so what is going on here now one of
the things I've been telling you guys
about for quite a while now
is the question about the symbolism of
the edge and the symbolism of what it
means to come to the end of identities
when identities come to their fringe
what does that look like and one of the
things it looks like is mixture where
two identities are mixing together or
there's confusion of identities or
there's confusion of integrity we could
call it and this is exactly what is
happening now people who want to defile
food which is you know a bucket of ice
cream or something is a an impulse
towards mixture and impulse towards
confusion and impulse towards the the
the mixing of identities and so you have
a bucket of ice cream which is which is
pure let's say because it's in a
container it's closed it's also you know
being sold and by licking it or spitting
into it or whatever what you're doing is
you're defiling it and and this action
of defiling ends up being a making it
impure and you would wonder why would
anybody do that but
that is exactly what the fringe looks
like that is exactly what the edge looks
like we have a mixture of you know a
blending of gender identities a blending
of different cultural groups all these
things are happening on the edge and so
one of the things I try to help people
understand is that the way the human
person functions we function through
analogies we function through meaning
and so we can't help for these meanings
to bleed out into other phenomena and so
if on the one hand we encourage let's
say let's say something like
multiculturalism on the one hand you
know the the value behind that will also
let's say leaked out onto other
phenomena and this idea of wanting to
make something impure or wanting to to
destroy its integrity is is a almost
like a ritual version of it and what
we're seeing by people doing this
publicly and filming themselves putting
it online is a mockery or a kind of you
could call it a caricature of a magic
action or a ritual action or you know a
kind of curse or blessing a way to
affect the world because what it's doing
is it's actually affecting the world now
when you watch a video like that of
someone who is who's doing that what
it's doing is it's it's not only is it
breaking the integrity of the actual
object that they're that they're
interacting with but it's also breaking
the integrity of our actual trust in the
manner in which society works because
now the question that is going to be
asked is has anybody else done this in
the supermarket and so I've tried to
explain this before but you can actually
see it happening in the in this action
is that when you start to confuse I'd
you know this type of mixture this type
of confusion of identity like I've said
so many times it is inevitable that it
would it will exist on the margins of
society you know on the margin of
societies on the margin of yourself on
the margins of anything there is a claim
we're identity start to mix where
there's exceptions where there's
inversions where all this is going to
happen it's a it's just an inevitable
aspect of this of an ontological
hierarchy of a hierarchy of being now
the problem happens when we make that
fringe into a value or we try to bring
that fringe into the center then we can
see the I we can see what it can do and
here we can actually see what it can do
because not only does it represent the
the let's say confusion of identities
what it's also doing is it's it's
creating a social breakdown it is
announcing a social breakdown where the
the the implicit rules in which we
function as a society you know all
holding to the same ideals is now being
put into question you know because we
usually trust we realized - how to what
extent our whole society is based on
trust and based on this trust that we
all share certain values in common but
when such actions are shown you know in
public what it's what it's doing is that
it's undermining the trust that we have
in the fact that we actually do hold
these same values the idea that someone
could do that you know all of a sudden
you're wondering well if I go to a
restaurant if I go to a store you know
you know anything any of these these
these these types of normal activities
we do are they being under mine by
someone who wants to defile it by
someone who wants to spit into it or
lick it or whatever and we saw this a
long time ago I remember I'm seeing some
images of this pop star ariana grande I
think it was who was licking doughnuts
and then photographing ourselves the
impulse to do that has to do with what
we could call the could call something
like the the great [ __ ] you know this
image that we have of the of the of the
great prostitute at the and revelations
or it in these types of in this type of
imagery is is the the prostitute or the
[ __ ] is an image of absolute mixture
you know the idea that that there is no
purity in the [ __ ] and so for let's say
a pop star like ariana grande who
has embodied that type of imagery it is
not surprising that she would engage in
such behavior and if you look at and
also the kind of people that are doing
this not in all the videos but in some
of the videos the type of people that
are doing this spitting into mouthwash
or licking the ice cream you will see
that some of them seem to embody that
fringe symptom body that confusion of
identity as well and so it seemed that
that is not surprising at all we saw
another version of this in a video of a
person who is who is licking a toilet
seat in it in a and an airplane and
everybody was surprising I think but
that's not surprising that is the
ultimate image of the great [ __ ]
you know the idea of licking the licking
the toilet seat that is wanting to all
the world all the residue all the oh
that everything you want to bring into
yourself or you want to put yourself
into everything so it could be one way
or the other the symbolism ends up being
the same you know you can't you can't
tolerate pure you can't tolerate even
even cleanliness is the is a kind of
simple version of it but the idea of
integral identities actually bothers you
you want to message in it you want to
you want to create mixture you want to
create some kind of impurity so that
there is no pure identity there is no
there is no identity which can hold you
know and so it's interesting to see that
this is happening and and yeah I think
that if you look at some of the what
happens in these articles it's very
fascinating because you can see that the
the reaction is the opposite and so
although a society usually is based on
trust when these types of things start
to come from the fringe and move into
the common space then the reaction is
you're going to create more protection
you're going to you're going to create a
lockdown you know you saw these images
of policemen standing in front of ice
cream haha ice cream containers and then
you saw people locking down the the
freezer so that you have to actually go
get help in order to access the food and
soap
this is it's important to understand
that that the human person has to exist
in a certain balance between identity
and and potential or confusion or let's
say exploration once you push too hard
in one direction the result isn't can
never be a total collapse in one
direction the result will end up being
this pendulum which swings and so the
further people push in there in the
direction of confusion and polluting and
breaking down identities the the
pendulum will also swing the other side
where there's going to be a clampdown on
identities a clampdown on on on
protecting the integrity of things and
so we have to be very careful we have to
be carried careful on both sides not to
pull the blanket too hard on our side
because like I said the pendulum always
swings a human person is made of those
two extremes and so you can't pull too
hard on one side as well and it shows me
as well to what extent our society is
based on trust and that we cannot we
cannot take for granted the implicit
structures which hold us together it
reminds me very much of a story of a
moment when when I was in Congo and in
Congo you could really feel like it was
a society that is always on the verge of
breaking down that is always on the
verge of erupting into a kind of civil
conflict or you know conflict between
the different tribes and everything and
I was really struck one day by a
professor the person who was teaching me
the local language in Congo Lingala he
mentioned something to me he said when
you go to someone's house it is very you
know you you can give them a Coke or
some kind of a drink and that's
extremely polite but people will never
offer you water and and if you drink
water at someone's house you can only
drink water at someone's house that is
extremely extremely close to you that
you you would never offer water to
people or you never ask for water in
someone's house even of a friend that's
just a let's say that's not your you're
very very immediate family
because there is this lack of trust
there is this lack of basic
understanding of what it means to ask
for a glass of water be until you you
get a closed coke bottle that you open
yourself because now you know what has
happened to this bottle you know that no
one has done anything to it or that it
had wasn't taken from a a polluted
source or that it wasn't you know you
know that it nothing was done to what
you are getting and so I really do think
that that's something that is we're
thinking about and always remembering to
what extent our society holds on faith
holds on these implicit hidden things
that we all trust that we have in common
and to watch how as we move further and
further out into the fringe how we're
seeing these bonds fray but we're also
going to see the other side which is the
clamp down so I hope this was helpful to
understand this strange phenomena that
we've been seeing and I will see you
soon if you enjoy the symbolic world
content there's a lot of things you can
do to help us out if you're not
subscribed please do go ahead and share
this to all your friends if you can get
involved in the discussion we have a
Facebook group in which people can talk
about these subjects I will put all
those links in the description and also
if you can please support us financially
by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com